vous vous sentez qu'il fa je crois que
toute mère se sent responsable tout
parent même homme ou femme se doit se
sent responsable de naissance de son
enfance si il n'a plus 18 ans ou 20 ans
si vous réfléchissez un petit peu euh au
fait de mettre un enfant au monde vous
vous apercevez très vite qu'on lui fait
pas un tel cadeau en fait ça serait pas
passé comme ça au 17e siècle non pas du
tout et le fait de la responsabilité
paternelle ça aussi c'est très nouveau
parce que le nombre de pères qui ont
abandonn leurs femmes et leurs enfants B
c'est c'est très nouveau effectivement
le la responsabilité on l'éprouve très
fort aujourd'hui c'est pas phénom votre
livre c'est une merveille pour les
avocats parce que moi j'ai une de mes
amis avocates quand je lui ai parlé de
votre livre je lui expliqué ce qu'il y
avait dedans m'a dit mais c'est
fantastique parce que enfin je vais
pouvoir plider la garde au
père c'est peutêtre pas mal non mais
vous conacre un chapit bien sûr c'est
pas mal mais quand même consacrez un
chapitre à ce que vous appelez je crois
l'idéologie du dévouement et du
sacrifice alors je crois que voilà
l'exemple typique non de la mère mais
oui sauf que chez Françoise renudo c'est
pas forcé c'est une vraie histoire
d'amour coignante elle elle se force pas
et c'est pas non plus un automatisme
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'il y a
desétas de femmes qui ont des enfants
mal formés qui ont des difficultés et
qui ne les supporte pas c'est pas un
automatisme je veux dire que moi j'ai
été frappé par votre livre qui est qui
est tout à fait poignant et quelquefois
difficile à lire tellement c'est
terrible mais j'y vois pour moi une une
histoire d'amour
étonnant pas un automatisme c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai voulu écrire
ce livre c'est pour que le souvenir de
cet amour insensé que j'ai eu pour pour
cet enfant mais pour mes enfant pas en
général mais là ça s'est concrétisé sur
cet enfant malade euh c'est pour que le
souvenir de cet amour demeure